nous sommes en direct avec cédric du bic
à vous dubuc pardon avocat spécialiste
des nouvelles technologies et françois
costantini géopolitologue bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir alors on va revenir plus en détail
sur les interrogations que soulève l ses
suspensions des réseaux sociaux mais
avant cela françois costantini
comment est-ce que vous analysez les
postures de facebook de twitter dont ce
contexte de violence au capitole mais
aussi de transition du pouvoir et alors
on le rappelle ans durant tout son
mandat donald trump n'a cessé de publier
des tweets polémique alors pourquoi
suspendre ses comptes
aujourd'hui avant de prendre sa décision
twitter aurait fait l'objet d'un intense
lobbying interne chacun sait bonsoir
chacun sait que donald trump était dans
le collimateur des réseaux sociaux pour
une raison c'est qu'il a remis en cause
quand même des abus de position
dominante pour la première fois
notamment pour pour google pour
instagram et qu'il a fait il a mis en
branle en quelque sorte une loi
fondamentale dans le larchitecture de la
régulation économique américaine qui est
le cheikh ben acte lâche herman de 1990
qui condamne à juste titre les abus de
position dominante et je rappelle que
facebook a été non google google a été
frappée en allemand de 2,5 milliards
record de 5 milliards de dollars
justement pour abus de position
dominante ou sectes règlement de comptes
pour moi tout simplement on assiste à
une régression de plusieurs siècles
oui de plusieurs siècles si vous savez
du temps de où l'église catholique était
dominante y avait l'index monde brûler
les livres qu'ils font n'est pas eh bien
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux sont
venus plusieurs siècles en arrière en
termes notamment d'un monde liberticide
privatifs de liberté et je crois qu'on
on assiste aujourd'hui à un 1984 plus
c'est à dire que je pense que george
orwell a été dépassé par la réalité
comment peut-on imaginer quoi qu'il en
soit un homme un président d'un chef
d'état suivi par 80 millions 88 millions
de deux personnes que sa politique
plaise ou non d'ailleurs cela n'est pas
n'est pas le problème
qu'ils soient autocensure et ça pose la
question également du devenir des
réseaux sociaux des positions de
monopole de facebook et ses deux
filiales faut dira d'ailleurs youtube et
twitter
whatsapp et twitter c'est whatsapp et
mis en cause justement parce qu'elle
s'apprête à des captations de données
notamment lorsque pour les personnes qui
sont pas sur facebook été touché tout à
fait scandaleuse et on se pose la
question bien sûr d'avenir de ces
réseaux sourire et peut-être est-ce le
début est également d'une nouvelle ère
peut être une multiplication réseaux
sociaux est intime justement qui serait
un bienfait pour les libertés
twitter a estimé que donald trump
inciter encore à la violence au
lendemain de la prise d'assaut du
capital est ce que c'est une
circonstance légitime pour fermer le
compte d'un président en exercice cédric
dubuc
alors ce qui est tout à fait étonnant et
je pense de scandaleux c'est que twitter
est un tribunal qui juge en première et
dernière instance qui statuent
finalement définitivement sur non pas
des tweets mais une menace
finalement une menace de violence je
pense que là on n'ait vraiment aux
confins d'un espèce de délire du
politiquement correct on rentre dans en
la vidant pense que physique l'aurait
appelle l' empire du bien et
l'argumentaire de twitter est tout à
fait étonnant puisque en réalité
derrière la menace de violentes twitter
ne recherche pas à incriminer le
président d'appuyer la première
puissance mondiale de tweets
mais en réalité derrière une recherche
prophylactique de le fait de rechercher
éventuellement un appel à la violence et
ni des tweets de trucks ont été
incriminés ni la vidéo d'ailleurs
censuré ne sont l'objet de la censure et
là c'est tout à fait étonnant et c'est
ce qui revêt finalement une certaine
complexité
en réalité le seul finalement
agissements qui pourrait éventuellement
appelé à une réflexion c'est la vidéo
dans laquelle donald trump appelle ses
partisans à marcher jusqu'au capitole
mais il leur demande et c'est quand même
excessivement important d'agir de
manière pacifique et dans le respect des
forces de l'ordre et donc twitter
finalement à nouveau dans cette danse et
de recherche prophylactique dans cette
danse et danse je le dis ce délire du
politiquement correct estime que
2 rennes 2 raisons qui font que le ton
le contexte va être bannie d'abord c'est
parce que twitter estime que le compte
n'est pas à soi disant au dessus de ses
propres règles et ensuite que twitter
agi de façon transparente
ce sont deux mensonges qui sont
excessivement je dirais évident de la
part de twitter d'abord le premier
mensonge c'est de dire que donald trump
ne respecte pas ces règles est que le
simple fait qu'ils ne respectent pas les
règles de twitter pourrait justifier un
bannissement parce que twitter a déjà
justifié par le passé que l'intérêt
public et je le dis solennellement
l'intérêt public peut permettre et
cesser la politique de twitter qui
apparemment évolue au gré de la lumière
de l'évolution politique américaine
l'évolution je le dis l'aspect d'intérêt
public peut permettre je le dis de
s'extraire des conditions générales
d'utilisation
parce qu'évidemment à travers ce
bannissement on soustrait un débat
démocratique
on soustrait la possibilité de débattre
je dirais d'idées et en soustrait je
dirais la liberté d'expression et je
rejoins tout à fait ce qui vient d'être
dit on régresse de plusieurs siècles
puisque la liberté d'expression c'est le
fait de ne pas être d'accord
la liberté d'expression c'est la source
du mécontentement
c'est la source parfois même de la haine
et il faut l'accepter et c'est l'objet
même de twitter que d'être un lieu où la
liberté doit s'exprimer et la liberté ce
n'est pas être d'accord avec l'autre
uniquement
c'est aussi être en désaccord c'est
aussi penser hautement penser contre
l'autre penser contre lui la déesse de
la liberté c'est eris c'est la déesse de
la discorde et je croise est
excessivement important j'ajoute
d'ailleurs que twitter et on l'a dit
d'ailleurs c'est ça ressemble à un
règlement de comptes
on peut d'ailleurs observer que le
compte de l'ayatollah le cas mais n'est
qu'ils soient d'ailleurs la destruction
de l'état d'israël
lui par contre est resté ouvert je fais
observer quand même que ce monsieur
qualifie d' israël de tumeur cancéreuse
qui doit apparemment l'état d'israël
doit pas apparemment être supprimés
selon cette hauteur là mais cette
hauteur là qui selon le selon selon la
constitution iranienne supérieur au
président le compte de cali de ali
pardon kameni est toujours ouvert
donc il ya véritablement une chasse à
l'homme une chasse non pas à des propos
mais à l'affluence où les effets que
pourraient préférer trop provoquer ces
propos et la question fondamentale c'est
est ce que twitter peut ou pas s'arroger
le droit de dire qu'une information est
vraie ou fausse qu'elle est bonne ou
mauvaise aylett inoffensives ou
dangereuses
de quel droit finalement bénéficie
twitter est ce que twitter est une
simple entreprise privée ou est ce
qu'elle est un peu plus que ça je pense
qu'au terme de cette décision il ne
reste plus grand chose de la liberté
d'expression et ça nous prive à tous
d'un débat démocratique qui n'en
déplaise à ceux qui en veulent à l'inra
donald trump ou à ses partisans je
dirais est essentiel pour notre liberté
alors on va revenir sur la question de
ce débat démocratique
ce que vous nous dites là à cédric dubuc
c'est que finalement il ya il ya deux
poids deux mesures et que donald trump
visiblement auront fait les frais dans
ce contexte de tensions aux etats unis
quand on voit comme une simple facile de
galvaniser les foules
est-ce que c'était nécessaire quand même
de couper ses canaux de communication
pour empêcher de nouvelles violences
françois constantine et non parce que je
pense que m dubuc va pas me démentir
vous savez que l'osq à une infraction il
faut qu'une relation de cause à effet et
en effet il n'y a aucun lien direct
entre les paroles de donald trump et les
violences qui ont été commises
premièrement en mètres du but le disais
précédemment en effet pourquoi youtube a
retiré la vidéo de m qui appeler bien
sûr la manifestation mais dans le calme
qui traçait des limites bien
circonscrite à ses partisans de
l'amender respecter les les forces de
l'ordre est de rentrer ensuite calmement
chez eux
deuxièmement il faudrait peut-être
également avoir une investigation
puisqu'elle quand même des appels des
idées des inévitables antifa notamment à
manifester il y avait un certain nombre
d'individus en effet don peut pas dire
qu'il avait des tas d visiblement des
désamours de patriot américains dans
leurs façons de faire et c'est donc
trois peut-être se se poser la question
un jour 2 de ce qui s'est passé mais moi
j'ai vu un véritable coup d'état le coup
d'état il a été fait il a été fait
aujourd'hui par huit par nancy pelosi la
présidente la speaker sert la présidente
en fait de la chambre des représentants
dont on sait les les orientations sont
très proches de l'extrême gauche à cette
cause
pas plus radical au sein du parti
démocrate qui a appelé ouvertement
l'armée notamment à priver donald trump
des accès aux codes nucléaires
ça s'appelle une forfaiture ça s'appelle
une tentative de coup d'état
c'est une atteinte à la constitution
américaine je rappel de la part de la
quatrième personne de l'état américain
après le président deux vice présidents
le président du du sénat et elle a donc
là la speaker de la chambre
c'est elle en effet qui mériterait
d'être déféré jeux de planches devant
gilles direction c'est elle qui a établi
un véritable coup d'état
un coup de force contre la constitution
américaine celle-ci pelosi pour moi
aujourd'hui qui a accompli un coup
d'état
donc c'est elle qui doit être remis en
cause et certains rapports pas donald
trump qui a toujours respecté en effet
tous les canons de la constitution
américaine
et je rappelle notamment le premier
amendement celui là moment absolu de la
liberté
on a quand même l'impression aujourd'hui
pour revenir sur le rôle joué par les
réseaux sociaux on a l'impression
d'assister à un paradoxe parce
qu'aujourd'hui finalement leur reproche
de faire ce qu'on leur a demandé de le
faire il ya pas si longtemps que ça à
savoir modérer finalement aujourd'hui la
question qui se pose c'est plutôt de
l'évolution des réseaux sociaux qui
aujourd'hui avec cette si grande si
cette si forte audience
finalement ils sont devenus un service
public ce qui nécessite donc une
régulation clair en coopération avec des
représentants élus démocratiquement
cédric dubuc
votre question est absolument
essentielle elle est elle d'ailleurs
elle met le doute sur ce qu'est twitter
est ce que twitter est une entreprise
privée ou est ce que twitter est un état
et quand vous avez finalement évoqué la
restriction qu'on propose aux réseaux
sociaux sur liberté d'expression en
réalité on ne suggère pas aux réseaux
sociaux de s'autolimiter on suggère aux
états la plupart du temps de limiter les
réseaux sociaux et donc la question
c'est est ce que twitter est une
entreprise privée et finalement on
pourrait envisager que ses propres
conditions générales d'utilisation si
elles sont violées elle peut bannir
donald trump comme n'importe quel
citoyen mais en réalité le débat n'est
pas celui-là tout le monde a conscience
que twitter est bien plus qu'une société
privée
twitter est et le canal sinon principal
du moins essentielle d'informations
twitter est un des éléments essentiels
du débat démocratique
elle le permet de par son canal
technologies
et donc la question c'est qu'est la
liberté que l'on veut pour twitter c'est
ça la question est ce qu'on veut
finalement être d'accord avec le
politiquement correct et avec la
politique de twitter qui fluctuent ce
qui fut tué selon sa propre oligarchie
ses propres élections américaines où
est-ce qu'on veut finalement accepté le
désaccord est ce qu'on veut un lieu
d'affrontement
ou est-ce qu'on veut un lieu où il n'y a
que les partisans de joe biden qui
échange entre est ce qu'on veut ce jeudi
restimuler jusqu'à l'extrême d'ailleurs
les partisans d'une dalle trump qui pour
le coup et à certains certains sont
peut-être adeptes de la théorie du
complot
je dirais ça leur donne raison
malheureusement puisque au lieu de les
laisser s'exprimer et au lieu de donner
j'ai c'est finalement s'écharper c'est
le lieu c'est le lieu de la démocratie
historiquement il y avait l'agora
historiquement il y avait toujours eu
des lieux de 2,2 ou là où parfois la
discorde là elle le désaccord s'exprime
aujourd'hui on interdit sans appel sans
recours
le premier président enfin le président
de la première puissance mondiale de
s'exprimer c'est absolument inouïe et on
est et on lui répond le on lui dit
gentiment mais tu n'as qu'à hambourg en
gros ferrand recours en tant qu'individu
pour contester éventuellement ce
bannissement
sauf que le débat est bien que large
puisque non seulement ça woerth donald
trump
ça apporte éventuellement ses partisans
mais sartre surtout toute personne tout
individu américain au nom qui a le droit
essentiel à ce qu'un débat démocratique
puisse avoir lieu
y compris sur twitter et pas uniquement
sur d'autres plateformes et d'ailleurs
on est on est bien normal de les trouver
puisque finalement instagram et facebook
ont suivi le pas à une plateforme qui
autorise ce débat démocratique d'une
personne avec une personne qui n'a pas
enfreint les règles et c'est là où c'est
absolument extraordinaire c'est que
aucun des propos donald trump n'est
incriminé
c'est simplement son aptitude éventuel a
incité à la violence on est vraiment
conditionnelle je suis pas un adepte
partisans à fann donald trump
je suis très en revanche très sensible
la capacité qu'on peut tout savoir de
débattre sereinement avec des idées
politiques qui ne sont pas les nôtres
je pense évidemment oui ça crée
évidemment un précédent en matière de
liberté d'expression sur les réseaux
sociaux parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
donald trump qui est suspendu qui est
visé mais demain n'importe qui d'entre
nous pourrait être aussi la cible de ces
réseaux sociaux est ce que ce n'est pas
là le signe qu'il faut aussi aujourd'hui
réfléchir à une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique c'est l'appel
aujourd'hui à de cédric au le secrétaire
d'état en charge du numérique français à
constantine oui bien sûr il ya quand
même sur le monde du politiquement
correct
il ya un vent de panique qui passe parce
qu'on voit que ces gens là aujourd'hui
son prêt à priver toute liberté
nous nous sommes nous sommes en effet en
pas encore en cas de régression et je
pense que les réseaux sociaux à partir
du moment où sont ils sont tenus par par
le monopole que que l'on connaît son
sont véritablement un danger de plus il
ya eu des lois notamment liberticide y
compris en france loi via et d'autres
qui viennent qui viennent se superposer
et qui viennent limiter la liberté
d'expression je rappelle quand même que
nous devons rester pour moi les réseaux
sociaux doivent être calqué sur la chine
de la presse nous avons une loi en effet
de référence qui la loi du 29 juillet
1881 où on avait aboli dans ses premiers
occupants des grandes voix républicaine
la censure préalable donc la liberté est
la règle et la censure qui n'est pas une
censure a priori me censure a posteriori
en effet doit demeurer l'exception et b
les réseaux sociaux pour moi ça doit
être la même chose qu'on peut pas non
plus interdire il ya des gens qui sont
condamnées en dégoûte presse c'est pas
pour autant qu'on a fermé deux qu'on a
fermé des journaux ou alors on vient on
se retrouve du temps de l'union
soviétique ou en effet vous avez une
règle générale d'une règle ans et un
prêt-à-penser pour tout le monde où les
autres ne sont que des dissidents
je crois qu'aujourd'hui en effet ce
kiosque au fond twitter ce que font
facebook un str adams et qu'il d'un jeu
ils induisent en effet aujourd'hui une
nouvelle dissidence avec les dangers en
effet que ça peut poser
merci beaucoup monsieur malheureusement
le temps lui manque merci d'arv échanger
avec nous ce soir cédric dubuc avocat
spécialiste des nouvelles technologies
et françois costantini géopolitologue
merci à tous les deux et bonne soirée